buongiorno siamo fare un tampone che
stasera c'è una cena coi parenti vabbè
va bene anche domani mattina al 25 c'è
lei mi sta dicendo come una pandemia in
corso questi temi si annota padre ma
questo spazio
allora non sei semo capiti a nel campo
ne serve per lavorare signori dove
faccio un mazzo tanto la mattina alla
sera mi dà su come voi che leggo le
ricette dei dottori euro come trovate
poste anche velocemente se non li faccio
saltare è stata al machete meta capito
no senza mia figlia avuto un positivo in
classico devo essere sicura che non se
lo sia preso anche lei la prego signori
non la pago il doppio signorina ci
servono degli altri tamponamenti
silvana sì siamo 18 ma come na li ha ma
sta scherzando ma io già girate per
farmacia ma non vorrà mica farci saltare
pranzo di natale quindi se chiamo sumero
me lo fanno cosa privatamente e quanto
si prendono stipendi del merda 200 euro
per un tampone maestra scherzare o male
vuole prendere le botte